In this lesson we'll look at Jellyfish,
a technique to network data centers randomly.
The goals of Jellyfish are to achieve
high throughput to support, for example, big data
analytics or agile placement of virtual machines
and incremental expandability, so that network operators can
easily add or replace servers and switches.
For example, large companies like Facebook are adding
capacity on a daily basis. Commercial products
make it easy to expand or provision servers
in response to changing traffic load but
not the network. Unfortunately, the structure of the
data center networks constrains expansion. Structures such
as a hypercube require two to the K
switches, where K is the number of
servers. Even more efficient topologies, like a FAT
tree, are still quadratic in the number of servers.